le maire de côte-saint-luc n'a pas
attendu que l'obligation viennent de
québec c'est la seule ville qui impose
le masque dans tous les lieux publics
intérieurs
on a une population très vulnérable de
30 % de notre population sait plus de 65
ans c'est le pourcentage le plus haut au
québec
devant cette épicerie on ne voit pas une
seule bouche
pas un seul n'est qui dépasse c'est
génial ses très bonnes dispositions
ça protège finissent le règlement mais
la responsabilité du côté du commerçant
qui risquent de 100 à 500 dollars
d'amendé
mais on promet une application qui ne
sera pas bête et méchant on va pas
donner une amende si envoyé à quelques
dans les magasins qui ne porte pas des
masses mais 98% des personnes portent
des masques mais on n'en est pas là je
chante avec l'été et c'est tout à fait
normal
un relâchement des mesures on sent
vraiment là que le port du masque des
gens sont plus proches les uns des
autres tout dans la nature nous amène à
nous rapprocher
avant que le gouvernement n'impose le
masque petite observation station berri
uqam à lundi matin entre 8h15 et 8h30
200 personnes passent sur cette portion
de quais 87 ont un masque soit 43 5%
pas de quoi réjouir l'une des trente
médecins qui réclame le port du masque
obligatoire dans tous les lieux publics
vous disiez dans votre appel au
gouvernement que il faudrait 80 % de la
population pour que ce soit vraiment
efficace comme mesure donc 40 sous 50%
finalement c'est comme si personne ne le
portaient c'est presque inutile
c'est comme de gâchage d'énergie ce qui
la moitié des gens font attention mais
les autres ne font pas attention c'est
on la mesure n est pas assez efficace on
s'est donné du mal collectivement
pendant trois mois et même plus ce pas
maintenant qu'on va avec un relation
juste parce qu'on est année on est tous
cette année on est tous cette année mais
juste parce qu'on est année on va
repartir à zéro parce que le virus est
toujours là sur les 55 mille québécois
et québécoises qui ont attrapé le virus
la moitié ont guéri mais ça ça veut dire
au moins vingt-cinq mille personnes sont
toujours activement malades et le match
protège surtout les autres 10 mois à peu
près 80% de mes particules je les garde
pour moi si je suis infectées sans le
savoir je viens de vous protéger et on
n'a pas besoin de respecter les deux
mètres là on est quand même assez proche
si certains baissent les bras c'est
peut-être à cause de l'accumulation de
nouvelles règles contre nature selon
cette psychologue comme le fait de ne
pas toucher de ne pas s'approcher au
niveau du port du masque
c'est sûr que ce parent de masquer leur
vaut aussi un peu contre nature dans ce
sens où on va cacher une partie des
expressions du visage une partie des
expressions faciales puisse aussi ses
expressions là sont commencés
fondamental dans toute la communication
humaine et en choisissant de l'imposer
dans les transports le gouvernement
devrait appuyer sa décision sur du
concret il va falloir aussi que ce soit
accompagnée d'après moi de bonnes
raisons de bonnes justifications de fait
solide aussi pour dire voici les
avantages à imposer le masque comme
cette étude de l'université de
washington selon laquelle si 95% des
américains porter le masque dans les
lieux publics
cela éviterait 33 mille décès aux états
unis d'ici le 1er octobre mais le masque
peut aussi être un nouveau carburant
pour l'économie demandez aux magasins
aux commerçants qui doivent laisser
rentrer leurs clients au compte gouttes
c'est pas rentable pour un commerçant
d'avoir six fois moins de clientèle puis
payer le même nombre de personnes pour
servir c'est pas rentable donc il ya des
magasins qui veulent pas ouvrir dans ces
conditions là tandis que si on impose le
masque mais beaucoup plus de gens
peuvent rentrer dans le magasin et faire
faire leurs achats sans nécessairement
mettre les otaries c' est ce que le
maire de côte-saint-luc s'est attiré les
foudres avec son règlement
je ne vois pas de résistance des
commerçants
je n'ai pas reçu des appels des
commerçants qui dit non je ne veux pas
ça et des mercis pour le faire et puis
les citoyens respectueux peuvent bien
aussi s'accorder parfois un peu de répit
de temps en temps je de temps en temps
pas tout le temps quand je suis dedans
non mais si je suis dont je vais vous
dire la vérité si je suis seule je
laisse ici mathieu prost radio canada
montréal